over the last two and a half years 89
songs have made their way into the top
five slots of the Billboard Hot 100
charts for this episode the team at
sound field cracked open every one of
these songs to identify certain trends
that are common in music right now what
our charts helping artists doing today
versus in the past
these days if you want to top the charts
it's better to use the sadness series
tones of the minor keys and modes rather
than the more regular major keys that
have historically been used at the top
of the charts from this graph we can see
that of all the tonalities use harmonic
minor and natural minor as well as the
minor modes of durian and Phrygian
outdid the appearance of major keys and
the Lydian mode by almost double this is
uncommon for pretty much any other era
of Western popular music even more
surprising is the rise of the Phrygian
mode in modern pop hits 7% of the songs
used it and while that's not a huge
number itself it becomes gigantic when
you consider that the overall usage of
Phrygian across all popular music ever
is well south of 1% in lyric writing or
any kind of writing or poetry a trochee
is when a stress syllable is followed by
an unstressed syllable so like trochee
Monalisa or bad and bougie these
trophies are in contrast to the more
common cousins i am big phrases like I'm
bad at love she walks in beauty like the
night or Havana unana what we're hearing
all over the pop charts these days is
that trophies are often being sped up
double time so what was two eighth notes
before becomes two sixteenth notes
followed by a rest we call these rapid
trophies and they sound like this
[Music]
actually maybe we should just call these
car Teatro keys because the last four
examples were of car D be using them
shadow to a Danny Lee's video on scotch
snaps where he digs into this more
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles so what
does the Billboard Hot 100 have against
guitars these days well let's first
mention that two of the most common keys
that guitarists have traditionally
written songs in are E and a major
[Music]
now I'll look at what's going on in
today's charts here we can see that
while a and we have healthy showings for
minor keys not one song to top the
charts was written in a or in E major
now let's take a look at the tempos that
chart-toppers have been using lately
okay so we have a small spike from 67 to
70 BPM but the real story here is this
big gap from 109 to 118 BPM with just a
little baby and gonna stripped to hard
sitting here at 112 like they didn't get
the memo but seriously this is not
typical the most common tempo in the
Rolling Stone greatest 500 songs of all
time was 112 bpm I guess modern pop
listeners just don't respect these
tempos anymore maybe they went out of
style one thing that still hasn't gone
out of style in pop music is the
predominant use of the major key triads
major 1 4 5 and -6 these chords still
dominate the harmony in a lot of songs
in fact 28% of the songs and major Keys
only use these courts in a very general
sense pop songs have evolved from having
one repeated section to two sections to
having three sections often organized as
verses choruses and a bridge as songs
kept evolving we started to see more
interlude sections into the mix such as
repeated intro instrumental solos and
pre choruses and finally the post chorus
is not becoming pretty common but we're
a pre-chorus warms up the stage a post
course cools things off before the song
returns usually to a verse sometimes a
bridge or another section songs with
post courses include
[Music]
I'm sorry to report that the modern pop
song still has a long way to go on the
gender parity front let's take a look so
not only were there twice as many male
solo tracks as there were solo female
tracks but only 8% of tracks had no male
vocalist at all traditionally both
Western classical music and pop have
really liked this home-and-away
interplay almost always beginning and
ending on clear-cut home chords but it's
really becoming less and less important
as the years go by and this shows up all
over on today's charts take the loop
from Drake's hit nice for what it's
based off of a loop he got from Lauryn
Hill's song x-factor
here the chords in the sample D flat
major D flat major seven D flat major
and F minor so the thing about this is
that there is a lack of reinforcement in
the bass there aren't any Cadence's
really and also there aren't dominant
chords these are all things that would
indicate a key Center for us for example
if we're in the key of a flat major
these chords might lead back to the
tonic back to home base we don't have
those signs we just have are we in F
natural minor or Aeolian are we in D
flat D flat Lydian
so it's really hard to say towards the
middle of the song we do here in the
base a little bit but still it's not
providing a strong key Center for us
being can you introduce yourself some
people know who you are and what you do
yeah when I was doing all of it I just
statistic I music you know I'm trance
Potter I suppose as far as tonal
ambiguity I feel like the tone ambiguity
can be having an on accident a lot of
times or it's like it's not intentional
a compositional decision that's being
made well yeah just just trying to find
and what sounds good to you rather than
what you've been trained to do you think
my little Johnny side boys did and then
you do an octave higher but it's like
that became a massive hit what makes
sense to me let's see use the analogy of
people trying out different clothes
people are more experimental with
everything with everything from color to
the shape of things and I think that's
what happens with music too like back in
the day like you had like functional
flaws like okay I'm going to school more
my school clothes does have a function
where my work clothes from sleep and one
of my pajamas you know clothes
ambiguities like what if I just wear my
pajamas to work or what you know like
and that's parallel with music
functionality isn't as important as it
used to be pipe lyrics and ad-libs are
nothing new to pop music but never
before have they been so prevalent
across the top of the charts
[Music]
it's what I like that's what we like and
if you can't think of what to say just
ad-lib yeah there's also a lot of A's
everything we've discovered is just a
trend a modern rule so now that you know
the rules of modern pop you can break
them so as far as creating the Billboard
- most all that every tune top-five tune
in the Billboard is got lyrics on it and
we only had lyrics on a couple of
soundfield Tunes but this one is one
that we just can't get around like you
gotta have some what's your background
Christina I do a lot of like soul
influencing or songwriter stuff la the
beats
they have this it's kind of round
naari your words and it's like you're
spot-on today stuff but so it's like
okay round and scooping rounded scoopy
ice cream and hard really good ice cream
one thing for this I would think
percussive I would think rhythmic choppy
percussive words you said not
necessarily rapping I'm saying but like
Billy Alice no pressure
we're just trying to live up to a
multi-million dollar budget track
[Music]
no I gotta go to Berlin that is just me
so baby take my hand you don't gotta
tell me twice I know you can make it
right oh yeah you Electrify baby you
just blew my mind
you don't gotta tell me twice I know you
can make it right baby you'll just blow
my mind PBS Digital Studios wants to
hear from you we do a survey every year
that asked us about what you're into
your favorite PBS shows and things you'd
like to see more from PBS Digital
Studios
you can even vote on potential new shows
all this helps us make more of the stuff
you want to see the survey thing is
about 10 minutes and you might even win
a sweet t-shirt the link is in the
description and thank you in advance
[Music]